we'll be opens with more than three
minutes of credits but so cleverly
disguised as it behind the nightly
habits of a large dragonfly that the
audience doesn't realize what they're
being subjected to you do Kay finds the
alien he's looking for but my question
is how did they know that he would be
mixed in with a bunch of border crossers
as we find out later the men and black
only know about certain aliens if
someone calls it in and when they do
reveal a sky they're surprised to find
out it's an alien named Mikey so they
would have been specifically looking for
him they just happened to be in the
right place at the right time for an
alien they had no idea was here also
illegal alien gag hidden under an
illegal alien gag is nowhere near as
clever as the movie thinks it is another
hairy division 6 there is no division 6
this is bull you guys share our line
down for word immediately though if it's
bull isn't it you jobs you can't have it
both ways movie either they buy this or
they don't men in black conduct this
arrest not too far away from the Border
Patrol guys and yes they have memory
erasers but maybe they could have
avoided using them this time by finding
a more secluded area it's not for this
aliens eye which totally gives away the
Border Patrol dude how would the MIB
know the civilian witness this or not
also why does Mikey go absolutely ting
haywire just because the Border Patrol
guys sees him he obviously knows the miv
and their methods for making people
forget about aliens like him but the do
flips out because he hates voyeurism hey
why does D have to shoot him you have a
gun too
this just so the movie can show why D is
in No Country for Old Men right now the
MIT Cleaning truck shows up literally
seconds after an alien has been blasted
so these cleanup trucks either follow
the detail and hang back a few miles or
else they're so plentiful and abundant
that no matter where the MIT goes they
can show up within two minutes sin
either way let's last I'm to ground
gasps vain genius you fellas need to
exercise a lot more caution before
discharging your firearm if this is
supposed to be a story that they
remember it is riddled with holes I mean
the only details they'll have is that an
underground gas main blew out in the
middle of the desert and for some reason
they discharged their firearms but that
detail will be missing goddamn who
jizzed into this guy to increase the
visible stars by a factor of 10
Michael Fassbender I'm looking in your
direction I will mr. chase
hello B you won't
so you wipe this 90 year olds memory out
in the desert near the Mexican border
why don't you just wait till you got
back to New York how's he supposed to
function around a life out here he has
no memory you might even think is it new
Illya
why you gotta be so mean to your
longtime partner k-j he runs this
newspaper truck down which is fine he'll
get a ride but isn't this truck moving
slower than he can run and therefore
it's moving slower than the alien ji is
chasing also I don't know what kind of
Street free was going on here that Jai
knew he could take this truck and
somehow be ahead of the alien but that's
the kind of scenario that's being
presented to us this reminds me the
stood is running around Manhattan then
why are the men and black not in on this
they somehow know about a dude disguised
as a Mexican who's in a van but they
don't know about this guy
Jai is addicted to guggenheim Will
Smith's character decides to run
multiple floors on a slow incline
instead of searching for the elevator
that will definitely be in this building
due to the ad a well it's more cinematic
this way anyway he's coming he's coming
because I failed an alien uses the
pronoun game because he basically knows
how much that annoys humans when they
need more specific information watch
that ledge watch the ledge seeing the
powers this guy possesses why doesn't he
just climb down to the street J would
never be able to catch up to him then
and yeah maybe he's just resigned to
commit suicide because he's coming but
that doesn't explain why he ran through
New York trying to get away from a cop
this whole time
apparently when humans loot their skin
it's all rubbery like a costume alien
Edgar drinks sugar water like I drink
wine Oh
I drink too much wine yes that's right
we've existed again why can't this wait
she's just gonna go back to work and see
the alien again anyway and he doesn't
even tell her a story remember I'm part
of a bureau that licenses monitors and
police's alien activity on the planet er
whatever
even though Jay has seen more than
enough evidence of an alien he decides
to play Dana Scully
sadly this might be Tony Shalhoub most
famous scene even though most viewers
probably don't know his name or any of
the other great works he's appeared in
like big night mom wings or hell even
cars
sadly Janey the whole dinner to help
forget about the proof of aliens he just
saw but everyone else just needs a
stupid story with minimal details so you
light his memory but you're still so
impressed with him you give him your
card so he'll show up for alien training
tomorrow without remembering any of his
actual alien encounters wow what are the
odds
Edgar scheduled an appointment with the
exterminator the day after an alien who
was related to cockroaches crash-landed
in his backyard leading to this alien
getting sweet expositional revenge
Will Smith who conveniently was off the
next day and didn't have any copping
today who decides to visit the hand
scrawled address on the back of the
business card he probably doesn't even
remember receiving last night that's a
ton wrong with that previous sentence
FYI
a single best gag in the movie has
nothing to do with aliens or science
fiction or any of that it's the simple
obnoxious table dragging scene
punctuated by Will Smith saying you
wanna get down on this and I'll even
take a sit on may I ask why you felt
little Tiffany deserve to die
I'm thinking you know eight-year-old
white girl middle to get a bunch of
monsters this time a night with quantum
physics books those books are way too
advanced for her Jay you would be
amazing at cinema sense but this kid ran
down a cephalopod on foot yeah but not
really
he grabbed a ride on a double-decker
tour bus in New York City at night then
rolled on the back of a New York Post
truck for a good while
I mean ran down is a huge thing
overstatement also how do you justify
recruiting new MIB agents solely on one
instance of physical brilliance that's
the criteria and surely you also recruit
a Brit barb after the dad game Michael
Jordan after the flu game and a bunch of
others should stock your core so deep
Will Smith character wouldn't even need
to be observed let alone recruited let
us thought the agency was jelly except
today Liam made contact March to 1961
outside New York and a cover up the
landing we held a World's Fair in Queens
three years later even if construction
of the pavilion started in 1961 or even
1962 why go through all the trouble of a
World's Fair instead of just packing the
ships on giant trucks covering them with
tarp and hiding them so these are real
flying saucers in the World's Fair was
just a cover up for the Atlantic why
often we hold it in Queens ha ha nice
Jabba Queens but could it be because
it's one of the most racially diverse
places on earth
I mean I'm slightly talking out of my
ass here because I guess this could be a
recent trend but surely back in the 60s
this was at least partially true at any
given time there are around 1,500 aliens
on the planet most of them right here in
Manhattan which makes it ultra
convenient for us since we obviously
only have two people hunting and
tracking aliens at any given time we
can't just pack up and go to Mozambique
anytime we want luckily anyone's haven't
gained that system yet the person is
smart people are dumb panicky dangerous
animals and you know it's going to
remove us in for the big truth bomb in a
summer action comedy what a great line
500 years ago everybody knew the earth
was flat the idea of a spherical earth
dates way further back than 500 years
way back in BC times it's ironic that
the idea that most people 500 years ago
thought the earth was flat is in itself
a misconception also it makes for pretty
scenery to talk about this in a park but
you also run the risk of someone
accidentally overhearing a conversation
and you need a sunrise thank you
and I will trust that during that time
you an unknown untested recruit will not
tell anybody about all the alien stuff
okay so even if ke knew for sure this
guy would show up out of was able to
time it so he'd be on the elevator when
dude showed up
okay just riding this elevator up and
down all morning until now I do see MIB
keep a room full of active weapons
behind glass just off the main MIB
concourse and if you want to say
education or training I'm still
wondering why the room has to be so
close to headquarters if it's going to
be active or why it can't be a room full
of deactivated weapons if it's going to
be so close to HQ somehow the first rule
of men and blacking is not never touched
the cockpit ball of horrific perpetual
devastation this thing caused the 1977
New York blackout and we keep it here
where it can easily be knocked off and
cause even more trouble if someone
accidentally touches it this real people
are aliens board joke is dated as
they're all late 90s people like
Stallone Tony Robbins then Al Roker
alive Ted Kennedy writing George Lucas
who's basically a time capsule the movie
makers and entertainers we thought in
the late 90s would still be relevant
today but we were wrong yo but I knew
our teacher had to be from like Venus or
something like that
Lisette Olson there are aliens that are
so common that they teach elementary
school and there are numerous
celebrities like Steven Spielberg George
Lucas and Sylvester Stallone who are
aliens there have to be more than 1500
aliens on the planet at any given time
like Kay claimed put it on Zed uses the
pronoun game when talking about welding
this movie went through the trouble of
showing one of Jays teachers miss
Edelson and showing that she was from
Philadelphia which is where Will Smith
was actually born and raised the
playground is where he spent most of his
days well why was his passport issued in
Indiana now the movie is saying Jay was
born in New York so this guy was born in
New York went to Philadelphia for
schooling managed to go to Indiana to
get his passport and come back to New
York to work for the police oh and also
be sure to delete his name which doesn't
seem to be connected to anything
meaningful on this screen other than it
just appears to be typed here this has
all the effectiveness of typing his name
in Microsoft Word and then pressing
backspace 21 times we are the man and
black roll credits
is there any reason this a boom truck
needs to have reverse lettering like an
ambulance on its hood do we need to move
over for extermination vans when they're
behind us in traffic also bad guy in the
Edgar suit can't drive first somehow he
still got all the way from the Midwest
in New York City while driving like a
moron
I don't think Vincent D'Onofrio gets
enough credit for playing this character
he is king phenomenal obviously sped up
footage is so obviously sped up I can't
get behind the idea of his car being
awesome you don't ever
touch the red model even though it like
everything else in MIB land is
completely on the open for accidental
touching that is Ivan devar Bob right
and somehow in this small restaurant
even though I've never met you I don't
ask questions about you being a waiter
here and you're somehow entered this
restaurant killed this guy and stuffed
him into kitchen shelves without anyone
seeing it and admittedly reading
backwards here but to these windows neon
signs read par kicks even if this is an
ethnic restaurant I'm pretty sure that's
gibberish on those signs there and will
you go in ready well it's my wife she's
gay not see this giving birth pregnant
lady she can tell just now the one that
came out here we were told that this
alien was stuck on the New Jersey
Turnpike but it appears he's stuck in
the middle of nowhere I mean where does
this and why did it sound the MIT alarms
only when he got out here stop showing
people are alien speaking on screen
these are a hot sheet even though can
spaceship crash-landed here a few days
ago the MIB who looked for aliens
professionally did not know about it
until they read about it in the world
how long has it been since the cockroach
alien crash landed on Edgar's farm and
the MIB haven't checked it out yet also
I didn't Edgar go ahead and kill
Beatrice volley was at it didn't have
any reason to keep her alive except to
give the MIB information later in the
movie and we have stories the best you
can come up with on a more personal note
Beatrice how does this thing work where
J essentially says I hate that big story
you gave her to remember while she's
under the influence of the neuralyzer
and she somehow doesn't have memories of
these guys making up stories for her to
remember a cat typically wheeled into
the morgue on top of their dead owners
Shannon I tried to verify this directly
only to find the subject was without
right one of the most overlooked great
lines in a movie ever as I watch these
two people bond over an alien autopsy I
wonder what happens with the coroner's
from other places that are not New York
City think about this for a second there
are approximately 1500 aliens running
around some of them they obviously can't
track what if one dies in Santa Fe
somewhere we sure there aren't like 25
medical examiner's out there who know
about aliens men in black steals the
quato from Total Recall and just rolls
with that like its original also got to
ask if this alien is only using the body
as a vessel
why is even close to death I do only
stabbed the vessel through the neck
which shouldn't have even fazed this
thing also this asshole is just long
enough to give the character some
information which is fantastic and
convenient
[Music]
Orion's belt this asshole calls the
cat's collar a belt even though he
speaks perfectly good English and would
know not to call it that Jesus zoom in
and hands cliche is way too good this is
a satellite image that somehow changes
angles but props to the movie for using
latitude and longitude data that
actually does correspond to the same
state we saw him looking at earlier
she's not gonna look up into space
basically at the satellite camera right
now he's off fast how do they know that
we don't
why does a rat desert his ship okay so
the reason why the aliens on earth are
trying to lead the planet is because the
arquillians are pissed off but their
Emperor was killed and they want the
galaxy or else they'll blow up the
planet my question is how did the aliens
on earth know this and when did they
know it remember Reggie well he
apparently knew about the attack before
the Emperor was even killed because this
scene happened either before or during
Reggie's attempted escape that's an arc
alien battle cruiser indeed it's also
way too closer to earth than it should
be for you to just be discovering it now
exactly how much does the MIB suck at
its job gotta love how keV freaks out
that Jay is aiming the noisy cricket at
him repositioned to Jay's arm and then
walks directly into the path of the
noisy cricket as he exits the shop
yeah but he's already got the shotgun
pointed at you and then you put it back
in your suit cause that's stupid you're
a dead man why do you keep your guy's
good thing Edgar accosted this random
street vendor about the more because he
stumbles on a picture of the spaceship
he'll need to get off this planet which
is the only one left there are so many
witnesses to the event in this shot that
aren't looking at the flashy thing about
to go off here that it makes my head
spin you don't like it you can kiss my
furry little butt movie inadvertently
inspires super overplayed drawn-out gag
in the sequel cab ex machina he's been
driving around then walking around after
that incident with K and J and it's just
casually carrying that rifle and no non
intergalactic normal NYPD style cops
have been called on the state is this
the only Morgantown apparently all
aliens end up here so that Laurel can
get her memory erased every week and the
bug finds this place immediately because
I guess New York only needs one more
just something
shinza well girl you ain't got to hit
the gas like that she points inward at
her vagina here instead of straight down
at the center top of the table because
the movie wants to make a fast moving
girl's joke instead of making sense damn
this bug keeps shining new powers to
kill people all throughout this movie I
didn't even need a shotgun with the tow
truck guy earlier if he's got some slime
that can stick people to the ceiling is
it a cat that feels vaguely racist bug
what does Jamie mean by decap does he
know which cab because he definitely
doesn't since they both ran out long
after the cat was gone out of does the
MIB claim to have kept this quiet
they can't flashy thing the entire
northern hemisphere so seriously nobody
see this impossible car driving on the
ceiling of the tunnel yes sir no reason
at all this future tech supersonic
forward as a goddamn 8-track player
because of course it does you ninny Shay
movie has time for this so seriously
why did he take her with him he
swallowed the galaxy he has what he
wants I'm shocked he didn't kill her
back at the morgue but taking her whisk
this is even more important question to
ask after she wrestles free and falls
into a tree and he just waved her off
like a joke keeps going why'd you even
bring her here dog I didn't mi D sent
everything they've got to the site of
the old World's Fair there are eight or
more working stiffs in this shot alone
but only J and K were sent to prevent
the war how is this not an
all-hands-on-deck situation wait a
minute even with the red button
technology it took K and J 52 minutes to
drive to Flushing Meadows goddamn I knew
New York traffic was bad but not defeats
the red button technology bad Shea
Stadium of all the New York Mets they
could use in this movie they chose
Bernard Gilkey this probably says way
more about the mid-90s Mets than it does
this movie also how are they going to
erase the memories of all these fans the
Starship Enterprise is always being
destroyed cliche wait sorry I got
confused still a sin for triggering me
on that Star Trek oh poor job on Omar I
want this why did they even give him
this much time in leeway if the
cockroach was this huge then why was
Edgar skin basically dripping off him
he's way too big to fit in it anyway but
even if he did wouldn't it be tighter
also they allow Edgar to transform here
instead of just blasting his face right
now is there any reason why the bug
doesn't just kill Jay right now we've
got your auntie by the way I'm not
entirely sure why this alien cockroach
which is way more advanced than his
earth brethren even cares about these
tiny insects you know y'all look alike
that's roaches I guess the digestive
system of an alien bug doesn't cause any
damage to a human being swallowed whole
also
this is only like the fourth or fifth
movie I've seen where a good guy lets
himself get eaten by a bad guy only the
slices way out of the bad guy's belly at
some point so you're curious tell them
we have the galaxy we totally beat that
alien in 18 minutes I don't even know
how this asshole is alive I just assume
it's some alien regeneration but what I
don't get is why this asshole screams
before attacking giving J&K some orange
also holy the rear southern bad guy
last-minute attack merge with the very
definition of an ex machina pennilyn
join in the partner of a training
replacement yeah but you're gonna retire
now she's only been on the job for two
days he doesn't even know how all this
works or the complexities of the alien
politics whether what not I cannot do
this job by myself hey guys hey guys
look who's not going to be in the sequel
even though this movie did everything to
try and make it seem like it was going
to happen I guess Linda Fiorentino was
way too 40 to be in the next movie that
ball that hit Bernard Gilkey was not a
home run unless they're talking about it
inside the park home run which the
official score would definitely not call
it since it hit the guy in the head and
would just be an error then called the
High Council is from school axiom 9 one
floor seats for the next full game this
is why you aren't going to be in the
sequel window your character blurts out
alien secrets around hotdog stands from
the episode of Doc's tonight why do I
always forget that Will Smith is also a
rapper
give wet shampoo bottle anyway the first
thing I don't remember too well but
there's about meeting them town
somewhere and give me some money
I think I lost it I look at you I don't
see an intelligent confident man I see a
cocky scared kid
the chair of genius will no one denies
that no one could possibly understand
the depth of you this is a class one
quarantine planet everything on this
planet has evolved to kill humans
[Music]
you're playing right here on this damn
so the red Buster kid don't ever ever
touch the red button factory right the
black in your poll he slimed me
welcome to earth the rock well I'm not a
clown